E aí
[Música]
oi
oi oi
[Música]
[Aplausos]
E aí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
O
que
é um prazer imenso a participar do Sedex
Nós somos o choro de Aveiro povo
brasileiro que não foi falado para gente
é muito importante
para nós brasileiros tá mostrando a
música brasileira a forma como foi
criada e para a gente é um prazer imenso
poder trocar essa experiência com você
é através da cultura brasileira choro de
Aveiro
E aí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
E aí E aí
E aí
[Música]
[Risadas]
E aí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
E para acabar eu queria a participação
de vocês em que vamos tocar uma música
chamada na glória do Raul de Barros e o
Raul quando fez essa música aí tá vendo
tem um casamento e no casamento ele
pegou um táxi e esse táxi perdeu e ele
parou em dois lugares o primeiro foi
Glória no Rio de Janeiro e aí ele depois
perdeu de novo foi parar em Madureira E
aí quando chegou no casamento resolveu
fazer uma música mas como todo música
perdido então vocês vão colaborar com a
gente depois que sair essa melodia aqui
e na glória
e de novo eu não
[Música]
na glória e depois Madureira
E aí
o e Madureira
e é Madureira Vamos tentar depois disso
a gente vai avisando né então vamos lá
é Pode ficar à vontade pode levantar
Oi
[Música]
[Aplausos]
tudo bom
[Música]
[Aplausos]
E aí
[Música]